panic panic is this different than how
you do it yes today I am going to be
shaving Matt's beard off
yes he is I don't like shaving my face
because I have very sensitive skin and I
believe it very easily good to know it's
your nerves that make me nervous oh you
don't trust me no I trust you I what I'm
worried about is that you don't trust
you this could really hurt my face I
know I really really like his face so
I'm gonna really do my best not to scar
it forever
[Music]
this is really cool it's like
finger-painting oh man it might get a
little bit lethal it's not going to get
lethal your hair so thick I'm like here
tell her your head okay I don't know if
I'm hurting you or if it's like just
coming off Oh does that feel terrible I
think you're going a little too hard
we're really here I knew your ear yes
it's everywhere oh no cross my neck like
you're slipping like the Rope this is
exhausted why do you think I hate
shaving no one's leading me okay I put
it there to me this noise it sounded
like I was gonna tear your neck open you
don't know what angle you're going and
thinking about it you can't like the
artists canvas doesn't talk back I feel
like I hold a lot of power right now I
don't because you're going to love you
but please just let me do they're gonna
kill me they're gonna give me a Lifetime
Achievement Awards gonna be for shaving
your face that's how long it's taking
this is like the saddest flavor it's so
sensitive is it I'm sorry
oh no no bleeding open like dots a
couple of them that's blood success
looks like mmm oh don't say that you can
say a word wow that was really hard I
was reacting to a vicious attack Bish's
attack it was a loving shave
oh good they look good yeah you look
handsome okay I made you look really
handsome thank you hmm well I'm never
coming back to you again barber did that
change your mind
barbershop I've ever been to I think it
just made me realize how exhausted I
could be and still love him
that make sense that's great I feel like
I look terrible
I think he looks beautiful no matter
what if you're just ripping skin you
need more shaving cream ma'am I'm a mere
man
I used a safety